marc landré est-ce qu'on peut résumer la
question de façon un peu abrupte
peut-être me direz ce qu'il vaut mieux
se faire manger par les allemands plutôt
d'être mangés par les chinois swiss on
peut résumer ça ça est ce qu'il vaut
mieux toucher être dans l'assistanat ou
travailler avoir un petit contrat c'est
toute la question est là
vous avez un monstre chinois ccrc qui
fait 18 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
qui est numéro un mondial et qui est un
véritable ogre qui non seulement travail
évidemment en chine mais en plus est en
train de conquérir les des continents
extérieur les autres continents avec son
matériel ferroviaire et à côté vous avez
en europe deux entités alstom transport
et siemens qui a eu deux fonds 15
milliards de chiffre d'affaires c'est à
dire - réuni que ce que fait chinois
donc l'équation elle est là haut c'est
une bonne idée
à l'heure où on veut construire l'europe
à l'heure où on est il ya enfin ce
serait complètement voilà en plus avec
les allemands je veux dire c'est un
amant leur certes ils se sont tiré si
vous me passez l'expression tirer la
bourre pendant des années entre siemens
et alstom ils se détestaient il voulait
pas se marier si elle faisait qu'y que
pendre de l'autre finalement il de gré
ou de force ils vont probablement se
marier mais oui est ce qu'il vaut mieux
se marier entre nous ou être mangé et
avaler et disparaître parce que la
domination chinoise l'emportent je pense
que quand on est européen
on a plutôt envie de se marier entre
nous et d'offrir une concurrence loyale
à un chinois